let's just say you come up and you see a
pattern I want you to go into business
with me meaning I go into business with
you and I say okay why don't you tell me
about your business and what you do we
sit down we talk phase one first meeting
I love it we go into Phase two you show
me a little bit more I love it even more
phase three we're sitting I see you know
what before we go into business together
I have a question for you say what's the
question what are some of your business
principles you say what do you mean
well if we were to work together there's
gonna be friction issues challenges what
are some of your business principles
that you build your business on and you
say I don't know today I want to share
with you some of my business principles
and I'll give you a feedback why it's
very important for you to have your own
business principles as well now the
business principles I'm going to share
with you is out of my new book that's
coming out August 18 called your next
five moves and for the next six weeks
I'm gonna give you excerpts out of the
book the next six weeks and each time
I'll share it with you and give you some
insight on what I'm thinking about with
that section of the book so let's get
right into it my business principles
here are some of them number one no one
has 100% job security including the
founder or the CEO let me say that one
more time
no one has 100% job security including
the founder or the CEO now you may say
pat if you're the CEO the founder don't
you have a hundred percent job security
no if you stop showing up to work and if
you don't come to grow the company you
staying home all their golfing all day
I'm sorry you don't have job security
I'm probably gonna go to another place
and run with somebody else and your
clients are probably gonna leave you so
business principle number one nobody has
a hundred percent job security including
the seal on the founder number two what
brought us here won't take us to the
next level
I just brought on a new executive we're
sitting on as we're going through the
process of hiring him and you know we're
doing all the paperwork I said listen
what's the biggest thing you've ever
done in your life and he tells me I've
done this I've done this I've done that
that's okay I said where do you see we
can go with value Tim and what we can do
here since I think we can do this and I
think we can do that and I think we can
build this big of a business I said I
love it you fired me I'm now here's a
question if you've never built something
like that what do you think is gonna
take to go somewhere like this that you
just paint a division he says I don't
know I said that's the point
what took you here ain't gonna take you
there to go there you
to change I need to change so the
mindset of we always have to improve
that's the second principle third one I
micromanage until I trust you what does
that mean well Johnny if we work
together this is let you say I'm sharing
my principles with you I'm gonna
micromanage you until I trust you what
does that mean well I don't know how you
work I mean we went through the
interview we sat them we had dinner we
broke bread I met your wife you met my
wife everything's looking good
but I don't know how disciplined you are
I don't know what time you come in in
the morning I don't know what time you
leave I don't know how longer the lunch
you take I don't know if you deliver I
don't know if you're just a talker I
don't know if you don't keep you I don't
know but I'm gonna tell you one thing
here I'm gonna micromanage and watch you
like a hawk until I trust you once I do
then there's distance and there's
freedom but until there I'm gonna
micromanage are you comfortable with
that I don't know if I like that but I
totally understand at the beginning
great number four never compromise not
mine you're non-negotiable so whatever
I'm sharing with you
I don't compromise these non-negotiables
I have in the past before every single
time it cost me money so I guess what I
don't compromise my non-negotiables next
one create positive peer pressure by
challenging one another what does this
mean here's what it means when we work
together I'm not going to be able to
solve all your prompts for you there's
gonna be times that culturally I can't
teach you everything but the team the
culture that we have there's gonna be
some kind of pressure you're gonna feel
not from me from the culture we have
created a certain culture that provides
peer pressure for you to step up your
game it's the kind of an environment we
have okay I get it fine
next one number six our entire focus is
to always beat our prior best if the
most money we ever made in a month is a
hundred thousand I want to make two
hundred thousand if the most we've ever
made is a million I want to make two
million if it's ten million I want to
make 20 million anything we've ever done
the whole ideas to beat our prior base
you with your department me with my
department we do that we'll eventually
get to that vision that we want to get
to I think that's very great next treat
the company's money like it's your own
money what does that mean let me explain
to you if the bank account you look at
we have seven million dollars in there
and you decide to go buy cameras and we
don't need a $50,000 camera but it's not
your money so you decided to go get for
$50,000
but if it was your own money you would
only gone $6,000 cameras you would done
a little bit more negotiation and you
would have gone three different offers
to make sure we get the best deal on the
table I probably would have done that I
want you to treat the company's money
like it's your own money I think that
also makes sense fern up let's continue
next one be radically open-minded but
not easily persuaded I don't know if I
understand that one let me explain I'm
open-minded bring up ideas tell me what
you suggest how to do this how to
suggest how to do that great all ears
but I know what I know and a lot of
things you bring up I'm not going to be
easily persuaded just because something
sounds great I may say this is not a
phase-one idea this is a phase-three
idea I may say I like what you're saying
it's not gonna fit with our culture I
may say I like the title you're picking
for this video but it's not the type of
title that we use over here I may say I
like the person you want to hire just
doesn't fit in our culture I like the
format you want to give this person with
a job schedule doesn't work with our
format that we have so I'm open-minded
bring it up to me but it doesn't mean
I'm easily persuaded with some ideas
that you bring at the end okay no
problem that's fair next one fight any
temptation to lower expectation and
standards what does that mean let's just
say we start growing and we're doing
good and people start saying how amazing
we are oh my gosh look how great they're
doing look at how much money they're
making look at how much just fight any
temptation to allow success to lower any
kind of expectation and standards oh you
know what guys don't worry about it I
don't care for guy comes in nine minutes
late it's totally cool I don't care if
you come two hours that it's fun guy
just leave him alone let him do he wants
to go out two o'clock every day it's
fine do it
we're not lowering standards an
expectation I'm just telling you for as
long as that's the vision that we paint
it and we're going there we're not doing
any kind of low expectation of standards
okay little bit unreasonable a little
bit crazy but fine I can work with that
great we want to keep the expectation
high fine last one I'm gonna give you
here create an environment where our
team is taking care of both financially
and professionally what does that mean
if my guys work very hard I want them to
financially make money based on what
their market value is I don't want to
pay you more than your market value if
your market value is 100 grand I'm okay
get in there if your market value is 200
you perform like a 250
you getting there but if your market
value is 50 I am paying you 150 it's
financially I want you to be taking care
for your market value if you push more
and I want us environment while
environment wise and fun wise to be in a
place where everybody's growing
everybody's having fun I like that as
well great no problem so those are my
ten business principle if you choose to
go into business with me so the question
comes back to you
what are your 10 business principle if I
choose to go into business with you and
if you don't have that down that's one
of the things we talk about in this book
your next five moves which is a project
I've been working on Simon with Simon &
Schuster and they're calling this their
business book launch of the summer
that's coming out August 18 if you
haven't ordered a book there's a couple
things I want you to know about this
book I almost didn't write this book I
almost didn't write this but because
there's no filters I'm sharing with you
my flaws my mistakes things that cost me
tens of millions of dollars it's all in
hearing things that made me a few
hundred million dollars it's also in
this book if you haven't yet ordered a
book go to your next five moves calm to
order the book and if you want to get a
free chapter if you go to your next five
moves calm you order a book send an
email to us we'll send you a free
chapter to read and if you text us at 3
1 0 3 4 0 1 1 3 2 one more time 3 1 0 3
4 0 1 1 3 2 the title next move we will
send you the link to order a copy of
your next 5 moves so you can get a
chapter and again for the next 6 weeks I
will be sharing an excerpt of this book
every week next week's gonna be sick
stay tuned
[Music]